[Música]
con la lluvia de sanciones económicas a
rusia por parte de occidente el gobierno
del presidente vladimir putin tiene que
tomar medidas inmediatas y efectivas
para así intentar minimizar los impactos
en la economía rusa ayer el ministro de
finanzas de francia aseguró que los
castigos económicos a moscú buscan
colapsar su economía hacia
específicamente china es la mejor opción
que tiene ahora sobre la mesa vladimir
putin beijing es el único amigo que
podría en este momento ayudar a rusia a
mitigar al impacto de los castigos
económicos pero el gobierno del
presidente jean ping tampoco le conviene
poner en peligro su propio acceso a los
mercados europeos y también los
estadounidenses por la amistad con
vladimir putin incluso antes de invasión
a ucrania el gobierno chino siempre
hablaba a la vía diplomática y también
al respeto de la soberanía de los países
y lo volvió a hacer en todos estos días
de conflicto aunque el comercio de china
con rusia se elevó a
146 mil 900 millones de dólares del año
pasado es muchísimo menos comparado al
con eeuu y la unión europea que suma 1.6
billones de dólares así las cosas
entonces saludamos a patricio giusto
consultor político patricio gracias por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
francia 24 le pregunto entonces como
china puede ayudar económicamente a
rusia me refiero a cuáles son los
negocios que pueden fortalecerse
bueno tú lo explicaba muy bien china es
un socio fundamental para rusia es más o
menos un cuarto del comercio bilateral
digamos del comercio global que tiene
rusia con el resto del mundo y
básicamente es una cooperación que está
centrada en lo económico en lo
energético en las compras energéticas
que hace rusia y en las ventas que le
hace china-rusia sobre todo de
manufacturas y algunos productos
tecnológicos y bienes de capital para
industrias estratégicas a ver pero si
uno toma la torta global del comercio de
china rusia es algo poco significativo
así que es mucho más la necesidad que
tiene rusia que de china en lo que es
esta relación comercial pero si luego
una decisión muy importante de la xxiv y
si el banco de china de cortar el
crédito a exportadores rusos esto es
todo una señal de que china obviamente
considera muy relevante esta relación
con rusia que han sido reafirmada en una
en un encuentro que hubo en el bilateral
por supuesto en el marco de los juegos
olímpicos de invierno pero la prioridad
es la estabilización de la relación con
los eeuu evitar futuras sanciones desde
y la relación con europa eso es más
importante que rusia hoy en día
sumergida en esta guerra que es muy
incómoda para china patricio a esta
decisión la tomo entonces china como
medida de sanción o para proteger su
economía
yo creo que es una señal son señales
políticas porque la verdad que esas
sanciones de cortar el crédito estos
exportadores en este contexto no
impactan fuertemente llegan o no tienen
un impacto relevante en la economía
china pero es una señal para occidente
diciendo nosotros respetamos el
principio de integridad territorial que
es un pilar de nuestra política exterior
mencionando explícitamente ucrania
entendemos las preocupaciones de
seguridad de rusia pero cuidado nuestra
expansión económica y eurasia y sobre
todo europa como pilares de esa
expansión económica en el siglo 21 de
china son nuestras prioridades y no
queremos más sanciones no queremos más
retaliaciones comerciales todo lo
contrario queremos afianzar la tregua
con los eeuu de occidente y estabilizar
las relaciones económicas de otro es una
muy mala noticia para putin porque si
sumamos en la foto la india singapur y
otros países que no están teniendo las
reacciones que rusia esperaba para
llamamos pero a eso le quería preguntar
primero como cala esto en políticamente
no en el gobierno del presidente ruso
vladimir putin
bueno yo creo que usted inició varios
cálculos que hasta ahora le han salido
bien por ejemplo nadie un
involucramiento directo de la otan la
población rusia rusa si bien ha habido
manifestaciones por ahora apoya toda
esta operación hay que ver como si él si
se desploma la economía rusa es
obviamente puede también convertirse en
un factor negativo pero yo creo que
putin tenía un cálculo de un apoyo más
explícito de un apoyo diplomático más
explícito de china y china por ahora se
está poniendo una posición de mediador
una llamada del primer del canciller
ucraniano a su par chino y ahora hay
mucha expectativa porque justamente
china tiene una gran oportunidad de
aparecer como el punto de quiebre en el
marco del conflicto quizás el único
actor relevante en el mundo hoy que de
alguna forma puede llegar a cambiar
edificios o la dirección por parte de
rusia en este conflicto así que
china quizás hasta lo veo como una
oportunidad diplomática de
reposicionarse en el mundo también
tratando de ofrecer una salida a este
conflicto obviamente estoy de ser
probable el uso es otro pero esperemos
no saber qué pasó y viendo hacia
entonces es como aliado patricio no
además de china con que otras naciones
podría forzar fortalecer sus lazos y sus
relaciones económicas rusia
yo creo que el otro pilar que con el que
esperaba sin contar es la india donde
hay una cooperación sobre todo no tanto
comercial es más bien en materia de
defensa la india es muy dependiente de
la cooperación de las ventas de
armamento ruso bueno la india también no
está teniendo la posición de
alineamiento por hay que esperar a putin
y se está manifestando una posición de
neutralidad y expresando preocupación
por esto el otro pilar te diría que
sería medio oriente donde también rusia
tiene fuertes lazos que tienen que ver
con la defensa bueno medio oriente hasta
ahora también está en una posición más
bien distante este conflicto que además
lo ve sobre todo lejano en términos
geográficos también y el sudeste
asiático malas noticias también con esto
que mencionaba de singapur en una
decisión histórica un país que siempre
ha sido neutral en estas situaciones
bueno está abandonando la neutralidad y
se alineó fuertemente con japón y otros
países de la región que adhirieron en
las sanciones putin estar realmente
quedando muy aislado y hacia está
incluido también en ese aislamiento y
eso creo que estaba fuera de su cálculo
depende de como escala este conflicto y
como avance patricio podría china
retirarle es su apoyo o no retirar de su
apoyo están concretamente pero si
hacerse a un lado completamente a rusia
yo creo que china va a aprovechar la
oportunidad no sólo en lo diplomático en
la escena global como te comentaba sino
también de tener una rusia más
dependiente obviamente esta alianza
entre rusia en china ya era simétrica
china es una superpotencia económica
obviamente en los militares están
equiparados pero ahora yo creo que china
va a aprovechar esta oportunidad de
asistir a rusia hasta donde pueda a
donde no lo comprometa con otros actores
como los eeuu en la unión europea y eso
va a incrementar en este contexto de más
aislamiento de putin la dependencia de
rusia para china y creo que ese factor
si lo va a saber aprovechar
patricio gracias entonces por su
análisis por su tiempo y estar con
nosotros en este espacio y france24 el
llamado directo américa gracias
patricios